Buzzy HBO shows Universal monster movies
and an unusual Suicide Squad role it's
obvious why Riley and the last of us
look so familiar in season 1 episode 6
of HBO's The Last of Us Joel ends up
taking a nasty piece of wood to the
abdomen and Ellie wonders if her newly
adopted father will survive judging by
almost every encounter the duo has had
in the past the odds don't exactly look
good in Ellie's eyes basically if there
was ever a time for a reprieve from the
relentlessness of The Last of Us that
moment is now giving the audience a
breather from Joel's harrowing presence
episode 7 tells Ellie's backstory raised
in the federal run military school there
is little room for freedom however Ellie
does form a friendship with another
student named Riley who ends up leaving
her to join the fireflies while the
fireflies are dubbed to terrorist
organization Riley is important to Ellie
in this world friends are few and far
between unsurprisingly a young actor who
has already appeared in many
high-profile projects was selected to
take on one of the most important roles
in the last of us so far no I appreciate
your mercy as a child storm Reed was no
stranger to acting but it was her
leading role in A Wrinkle in Time which
set her up for success and saw her
starring alongside Chris Pine Oprah
Winfrey Reese Witherspoon and Minnie
Kaling A Wrinkle in Time is known to
many because it's based on a classic
science fiction children's book written
in the 1960s by Madeleine lengold the
story was the start of a five book
series about Meg Murray and the search
for her missing father 2018's feature
film wasn't the first time the book was
adapted but it did break many barriers
in the process with Selma director Eva
Duvernay at the helm the film gives an
alternate perspective to a book that was
released over half a century ago casting
Reed in the lead role contrasted with
previous adaptations and was a
significant step for representation even
though Duvernay theorized that not
everyone would appreciate the casting of
a young girl of color in the leading
role many found merits in a final
product despite the fact that the film
received mixed reviews it remains a
beautiful and sweeping story that stays
true to the book Reid would later
reunite with Duvernay in 2019 for the
director's acclaimed limited series when
they see us based on the tragedy of the
Central Park in that project she played
Lisa the real-life girlfriend of Corey
wise
the universal monster universe never
really took off but Lee wanell deserves
respect for his updated version of
classic movie The Invisible Man starring
Elizabeth Moss the 2020 film follows one
woman's attempt to rid herself of
abusive ex-boyfriend Adrian who just so
happens to be a tech genius the
Insidious abuse that Cecilia experienced
during their relationship was so severe
that she doesn't believe it when she's
told that Adrian has died from suicide
unfortunately for her and those around
her she's proven right when Adrian
resurfaces with technology that allows
him to be invisible everyone suffers
especially Sydney played by storm Reed
the daughter of Cecilia's friend James
Adrian hits Sydney when only Cecilia is
in the room framing her for the attack
Sydney is the ultimate innocent in the
situation unable to understand what
happened to her Cecilia eventually gets
a better of her ex at the end of the
Invisible Man but not before so much
damage is done Reed doesn't have a large
amount of screen time but she does
exemplary work and displays
heartbreaking emotion and one of the
most uncomfortable scenes in the entire
movie
DC's 2021 reboot of 2016 Suicide Squad
came with many surprises both delightful
and heart-wrenching after his Marvel
tenure James Gunn arrived in the
director's chair to keep what worked
from the previous film and set
everything else on fire in a wise move
he kept Margot Robbie as Harley Quinn
and Joel Kinnaman is Rick Flagg for an
all-new adventure opting to remove Jared
Leto's Joker in their character's
controversial relationship with Harley
from the suicide squad gun instead
decided to tell a universal story about
the power of family we're all gonna die
I hope so at the center of this story is
Bloodsport played by Idris Elba who's in
prison for trying to kill Superman as if
that wasn't enough to prove he's no hero
he also happens to be a terrible father
because of his past with his own father
Bloodsport pushes away his daughter
Tyler it was played by Reed when she
visits him in prison but Underneath It
All He does care for her in fact Amanda
Waller blackmails Bloodsport into
joining The Suicide Squad because of his
love for his daughter and through all
his trials and tribulations he takes one
step closer to being a worthy father
HBO's hit teen drama Euphoria star
Zendaya as drug addicted High School Rue
and the series focuses on the sharpest
experiences of growing up class
relationships are at the center of the
series and that includes a conflict Rue
has with her family in season 2 Rue has
a dramatic relapse which culminates in a
harrowing scene between her and her
sister Gia it was played by Reed while
the sisters have a profound Bond the
foundation of the relationship is shaken
to its core at such a young age Reid
demonstrates that she has an acting
range on par with her emmy-winning
co-star discussing her off-screen
relationship with Zendaya retold L
Australia it's important to have some
conversations and get to know a person
before you were doing these emotional
scenes with a person with so many
incredible performances under her Bell
to read star is only going to rise
further following her appearance on the
Last of Us
foreign